[Musique]
voilà c'est fini la dernière saison de
l'amour est dans le pré touche déjà à sa
fin l'occasion de se faire un petit
bilan et le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est que cette seizième saison n'a pas
fait que des heureux et pourquoi comme
delphine et ghislaine qui se disent bye
bye après une idylle tgv aussitôt
rencontré aussitôt débarqué tout comme
franck les est-il pour la jolie histoire
d'amour aura connu les montagnes russes
un début avec des pommes d'amour et une
arrivée en chamboule tout je pense qu'à
toi chacun un je t'aime je pense tout
haut
mais que nos coeurs thorn sera sur nos
agriculteurs n'ont pas tous pris des rtt
et répondu aux questions gênantes de
karine sans raison certains ont trouvé
une loi leur tracteur comme
jean-françois l'ariégeois et mélanie
sans le vigneron et marie-jeanne ou
encore hervé stéphanie ce dernier coup
par le même d'un projet d'enfant atos et
par quand le bébé quoi c'est le souhait
de chacun une saison qui nous a réservé
deux jolis moments j'ai eu un coup de
coeur c'est vrai sur toi
[Musique]
mais aussi comme toujours des moments de
gêne
en fait c'est l'effet
saison en demi teinte du côté de l'amour
mais très réussi côté rigoler
voilà
enfin isabelle
fracassé mois ce programme c'est la
saison de la copulation
j'avais pas elle est ridicule entre
cette femme et c'est vrai il ya il fut
un temps bois vous vous je vous
demanderais même pas votre avis
nettoie et défendez l'indéfendable
quand on voit se marier le couple hervé
lala le arriver à celui qui était plus
haut oui c'est ça lui a bien compris
l'air las et puis bon sens
alors oui alors l'une a fait l'émission
c'est devenu un bang bang bang bang bang
l'émission j'ai travaillé mais attendait
le grand talent gagnante est comme ça
oui moi j'aime pas du tout
et puis alors il n'a et n'a aucune
pudeur et là je vous ai pris un petit
extrait là un petit florilège de sa
femme qu'il a fraîchement donc à
rencontrer
comme ça de cépet voilà alors c'est ça
l'amour est dans le pré
l'amour est dans le pré est maintenant à
le regarder c'est regarder cette
émission pas très drôle sur good extrait
là c'est dégueulasse voilà moi j'ai pas
trop dormi elle pas du tout même
[Musique]
voici pourquoi dire ça des surprises
et des gaz la nuit
je ne vais pas me sauver les
bateaux ça se dit pan
sport
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça l'amour c'est comme ça qu'on
parle d'amours attaché aux français je
vous ai plus grands hôpitaux
mais moi c'est mon métier
et d'en percer dans personnages
on va demander si vous êtes baladeur
mais paix mais non papa télévision
française alors daniel morose allez-y
des fournées cette édition de cette
émission
évoqué la volonté de la télé réalité et
le naturel de l'amour est dans tes
désolé ça fait du bien il ya plein de
gens qui sont comme ça chez eux on
n'avait jamais à la télé on les voit une
fois de temps en temps sur m6 avec cinq
ans et bah tant mieux ça c'est pas de
sophos un script suicides en un mot
c'est authentique alors là je peux vous
dire que c'est c'est absolument scripté
c'est absurde pour tenter c'est que mon
sens journée jeudi à leurs désirs tu va
nous raconter bien commencé bien avant
lui révèle comment et quand tu pètes
bien
aimée ou balade aimer ou ne pas aimer
pourquoi ça marche ces démissions c'est
un peu bien sûr c'est pas anxiogène à
quoi sert un cocon à
contrôler ses loyaux je veux enlever et
c'est pas d'accord avec ce que moi je
joue des chansons les gens regardent
autant c'est parce qu'ils aient plus on
rit il se réduit et héritera mais c'est
moi j'ai le temps de mourir dépend des
ondes qui avait claironné ouais bravo
je voulais encore
en
raison des pays bas
en effet on les paye alors gallas eric
abidal hors série devait de rendre
service et reid il n'est pas question de
dépenser un euro pour des missions
ah non
alors je dois je dois maîtriser les
cordons les commandes la bombe de cette
émission je suis l'animateur il n'est
pas question que siri dépense trop
d'argent comment bien les missions jeu
peut animer la scène demeure
[Rires]